Usa la propiedad distributiva para expandir la expresión.
6 que multiplica a "-4w" más 1/2 y déjame
sacar por acá mi bloc de notas para que podamos
trabajar este problema y bueno, lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que este 6 de aquí,
lo que va a hacer es multiplicar a toda esta
cantidad y por lo tanto,
déjame escribir esto de la siguiente manera,
esto es lo mismo que 6 que multiplica a "-4w"...
déjame ponerlo con este color...
"-4w" y a esto le voy a sumar...
lel voy a sumar 1/2, ok.
6 que multiplica a "-4w" más 1/2 y bueno,
esencialmente lo que tenemos que hacer es
distribuir este 6 multiplicando primero,
a esta cantidad y después multiplicando a 1/2.
Y me va a quedar lo siguiente,
déjame escribirlo de esta manera,
6 que multiplica primero a "-4w"...
a "-4w" y después a...
déjame ponerlo de esta manera...
6 va a multiplicar...
más 6 que va a multiplicar a esta otra expresión,
que es 1/2...
1/2...
De lujo, entonces tengo esta expresión de
aquí y esto va a ser igual a 6 por "-4w",
bueno, pues eso es "-24w", ok, y después
6 por 1/2 bueno pues eso lo mismo que 3.
Por lo tanto, llegué a la respuesta "-24w" más 3,
así es hora de escribirlo justo por aquí.
Tengo "-24w" más 3, lo voy a poner aquí,
"-24w" y a esto le voy a sumar 3, ok,
es hora de comprobar la respuesta y..
De lujo, estamos bien.